[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مجددا عاده شوارع البيروك تضج بالاحتجاجات
التي اعتادت عليها خلال السنوات الاخيره
انما بوجوه وعناوين شديده
مؤيدون رئيس المعزون تدعو كاسيو ومعظمهم
من المعلمين الذين كان يمثلهم وسكان
الاصليين والطبقه الفقيره خرجوا للمطالبه
باعادته الى السلطه واسقاط البرلمان
[موسيقى]
لانه يخالف قرارات الشعب ومن انت اخذناه
باصواتنا ومن يجب ان يبقى في الحكم ولهذا
سنبقى في الشوارع
حاول حل مجلس النواب هذه الاغلبيه اليمنيه
وفرضى حاله الطوارئ وصياغه دستور الجديد
عبر سلسله من القرارات الاستثنائيه
للمكافحه الفساد وفق انصاره لكن المطاط
انتهى به الى الاعتقال في سنه للشرطه
ويوجه له خصومه تهاما بمحاوله الانقلاب
على الدستور
الجيش رفض تنفيذ اوامره وسارع البرلمان
الى عزله وتم تعيينه نائبه الرئيس المعزول
وهي من نفس حسبه رئيسه بعد انضمامها الى
صفوف معارضيه
جرت محاوله انقلاب في بلدنا قادها السيد
بيدروكاستريو بما يخالف دستور لكن هذا
البرلمان قام بدوره دستوري وكلفني بتسلل
منصب رئاسه وانا ستحمل هذه المسؤوليه
وادعوكم جميعا للوحده في هذه اللحظه لما
فيه مصلحه بلدنا بتسلم اول امراه حكم
البيرو تكون البلاد قد استبدلت سته رؤساء
خلال اربع سنوات فقط في احداث وصراعات
عاصفه المشهد السياسي
النظام في القروب باسم نهارا من الداخل
بسبب الصراع بين المؤسسات فقد شهدنا
تغييرا ست رؤساء وسبع حالات شهور رئاسي
منذ عام 2016 اما بسبب شبهات الفساد
والاتهامات او بسبب مصالح شخصيه في
البرلمان لا احد باستطاعته ان يجزم ما اذا
كانت ازمه الحكم في البيروك ستنتهي على يد
اول سيده تسكن هذا القصر بعد ما اعلنت
نيتها البقاء فيه حتى عام 2026 الا ان ما
يشغل بالبيروفين على ما يبدو ليس مده حكم
رئيسهم او هويته بل قدرته على حل ازماتهم
التي تزداد تعقيدا وتركما حسن مسعود
الجزيره لما عاصمه البيرو